-Welcome back to the show.
Thanks so much for coming back.
-Thank you for continuously
allowing me to come here.
-What do you mean?
We -- We love you here.
There's so much I want
to get into here.
But first, I --
I just want to --
Everything's going on
with you and Justin.
You've had a rough couple
of months.
How is everything going?
-Everything is good.
I -- I'm doing okay.
My -- my health scare
has, you know --
We've -- We've moved on from it.
-Yeah, you look good.
-And I'm just kind of
allowing my body the time
to heal and do its thing,
but I'm doing okay.
He's also doing okay.
-Okay. Good.
-Obviously, it's been
a weird turn of events
the last couple months
and the last even few days.
-Gotta be scary.
-But he's okay.
And he's gonna be totally okay.
-Okay. Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy.
Have to -- Have to ask.
You have a giant career
and a giant career ahead of you,
but now you finally have
your own skin-care line.
And we were talking about this.
This was years ago.
-Yeah.
-We were discussing this.
-This -- You know,
I was looking,
and it's been almost ten years
since you moved to the city
to start modeling.
-Yes.
-And look at you now.
But I mean -- But what --
What do you remember
about those days?
-You know, I moved
into the city when I was --
I was 17.
I kind of had an agreement
with my parents.
I had really
just started modeling
and I was begging them like,
"Let me move into the city.
Please.
It's so much easier
for just everything,
for travel and for castings."
And they were like,
"Absolutely not,
unless you can afford it
on your own."
And I was like, "Okay, deal.
If I book a job
where I can afford it,
my own rent for the whole year,
you have to let me move out."
And I booked my first job,
and it was for the whole year
of rent, like, to the dollar.
So I was like, "You said..."
-"You said, so I..."
-So, I moved out, but I --
I lived with my older sister
until I turned 18.
But something
that I vividly remember
about moving into the city and
having my first apartment was --
I was out to dinner
one night with Justin.
-Yeah.
-And he was like,
"So you got your own place.
How's it been?"
Like, "You got
all your furniture?
You have everything you need?"
And I'm like,
"Yeah, it's amazing.
I love it.
You know, I have a couch.
It's great. I have dishes.
I have spoons."
-It's a big deal.
It's a big deal. Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, like,
everything is such a big deal.
And he's like,
"Well, that's amazing."
Like, "Is there anything
you don't have yet?
Is there anything,
like, you're missing?"
And I'm like, "Yeah,
I don't have a TV yet,
but it's like --
I'm gonna get one.
It's, like, not a big deal."
And he was like,
"Okay, okay, cool."
And then he was driving me home,
and on the way he was like,
"I can't do this.
We got to go to Best Buy."
[ Laughter ]
So he took me to Best Buy
on the way home,
and I was, like,
mortified because I'm like,
"You're not
about to buy me a TV."
And he bought me a TV.
-No way.
[ Audience awws ]
-And he -- he carried it up --
he carried it upstairs himself.
He unboxed it,
did the whole thing.
It was really cute.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Justin, you're a good man.
You're a gentleman.
-I still have the TV
to this day.
-You still have it?
-I still have it to this day.
I could not get rid of the TV,
you guys. It was too cute.
-Yeah, you can't
get rid of it now.
-No, it's -- it's still
in our apartment to this day.
-Yeah, you have to keep it.
-Yeah.
-Who -- Who got you
started in fashion?
Who got you interested?
Do you -- Was it your mom?
Your sister?
-I mean, I definitely always
looked at my mom's style
and admired it and I felt like
she was always was --
was passionate
about clothing and fashion.
But I would say
I definitely was inspired
in the modeling space
from the greats --
Kate Moss, Christy Turlington,
Naomi Campbell.
-And then I read somewhere you
named those icons and you said,
"And also Hannah Montana."
[ Laughter ]
-Um, yeah.
I -- I technically was also
very fashion-inspired
at the time by Hannah Montana,
a.k.a. Miley Cyrus.
She used to wear --
-I mean, that's --
A lot of people out there
feel the same way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right?!
She used to wear, like,
outfits on "Hannah Montana"
that I would try to recreate
because I thought they were
just, like, everything.
-Yeah. I never knew that
your middle name was Rhode.
-Yes. It's also
my mom's middle name.
-A beautiful name.
R-H-O-D-E. I love that.
I go, "Oh, and that is the name
of your new line."
-It is.
-"Rhode."
Are you -- Today is
officially -- This is real now.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Uh...
What -- What made you go like,
"I have to do it"?
I mean, I'm assuming everyone
just asks about your skin-care
routine all the time and --
-Yeah, it definitely was, like,
the thing I would get
asked about the most,
especially even working
with different makeup artists.
They would always be like,
"What do you do for your skin?"
It was just always something
I felt really passionate about.
I was always someone who is,
and still am,
clearly, to this day,
very committed to a routine,
very regimented person
who is, like, very OCD
about a skin-care routine.
And I just felt like over
the last almost ten years
of working in this industry,
I felt like I was really able
to develop my beauty philosophy.
And I got to a point
where I was like,
"I want to make a curated,
edited line of essentials,
like, my go-to things
that can work for everyone."
So the way I --
-Did you always know the name
"Rhode" was gonna be the title?
-I wasn't sure
in the very beginning.
I always knew I wanted "Rhode"
to be a brand that I started.
And as I was developing
and having the conversations
about the skin-care brand,
"Rhode Skin"
just kept calling me
and coming to me.
And I also felt like
it was very fitting
because my mom taught me so much
about taking care of myself
and skin care and sun care
and all these different things.
So I thought there was a really
nice story there with the name.
-Yeah. I -- I know
you released this as a teaser,
and I want to ask you about this
because I think it's funny.
And there's you
posing with a doughnut.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, that is me.
-Yeah, I --
Yeah, a glazed doughnut.
And -- And then I was like,
"Okay, there must be
something to this."
-Yes.
-Because I was like, "What..."
It's you and
the glazed doughnut.
But it went everywhere.
And then you said that
when you go to bed at night,
you want to feel -- you want
to look like a glazed --
-I want to give off the vibe
of a glazed doughnut.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
-Like --
-Edible, dewey,
yummy, delicious.
-Dewey.
-Glazed.
-I loved that that is your --
that's your thing
you want to do.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ] You're also
doing something really cool
that I want to mention called
the Rhode Futures Foundation.
-Yeah, so --
-You're using some of
the proceeds to help women.
-Yes, we are using proceeds
from Rhode to hopefully
in the first year support
and help a thousand women
through three different
amazing organizations.
-See? Come on.
That's how you do it, buddy.
You give back. You work so hard.
Congratulations.
It's officially out.
-It's officially out.
-I'm so happy you're here.
-Thank you.
-You look fantastic. Thanks.
Come back whenever you want.
Hailey Bieber, everyone.
Check out her new skin-care line
"Rhode,"
which is available right now.
We'll be right back
with Austin Butler.
Stick around. Come on back.